[Music]
[Applause]
Tom verduchi in 2020 did one of the only
long sitdown interviews for Sports
Illustrated with uh Sho Otani and had a
great summary of exactly what's going on
here in the recruitment the courtship of
shoh Otani but also there's some
tentacles here that uh you're trying to
figure out of how much is he going to
get paid deferring this money does
baseball say anything about this can
baseball say anything about this so why
not just have Tom verducci on from uh
MLB Network and Fox Sports and Sports
Illustrated let me start with the
contract here how much is shotani
getting paid this year and how much
money does that affect their salary
cap he's getting paid less than Austin
barns the backup catcher for the Dodgers
he's getting paid $2 million a year
that's it that's how much present day
value that's how much the the checks are
going to add up to this year
2024 and what he's done is he's taken
that number which is 70 million a year
right 700 over 10 years 70 a year and
he's reduced that number in present day
value as far as the luxury tax goes
because that's the number that really
matters in baseball they $4 46.6 million
and what does that do it puts about $24
million back in the pockets of the
Dodgers to spend so they just signed
this guy for $700 million and they're
going ahead and they're negotiating with
yobu Yamoto the best free agent pitcher
coming out of Japan this year and that
number is going to be close to 300
million and they're also talking to Josh
hater this is not possible unless Otani
takes 97.1% of his money do him and says
just pay me later on 10 years down the
road with no interest by the way
incredible the way he has allowed the
Dodgers to have the most expensive
player in any sport history and still be
affordable has anybody ever done
this not to this level the record for
the highest percentage I'm not sure
about other sports in baseball 50% and
that was Max sherzer signed a contract
with the Nationals $210 million 105
million of that was deferred there might
have been some interest attached to that
but 50% no one else is really close
we've had guys 20% mie bets maybe 20
something percent uh so there was
nothing like this and this always Show's
like he went to his agent Nez bolo and
said listen what if I defer all my money
down the road they don't have to pay me
anything and he Nez looked into the CBA
and first of all there's no provision
about some cap you can't defer 97% of
your money the only provision is you
have to take some money you can't play
for free minimum salary next year is
740,000 they settled for some reason on
two million um but that was sh's idea he
wanted to go to a team and realize
realiz that I'm not hamstring this team
going forward like yeah you got me but
what do you got around me there's plenty
around him now with the Dodgers there
was and there will be take me back a
week ago now I guess everybody's allowed
to talk about this of what happened with
shotani nobody's going to get penalized
how many teams and really was who was
the second who was the runner up here it
was down to just the Dodgers and the
Blue Jays that was it it started out as
it did its first time he was a free
agent when he was leaving Japan did not
want the East Coast did not want the big
cities on the East Coast did not want
weather that's a big part of it it it
had to be climate controlled environment
or Southern California which is what he
knows he is there's two things sh does
in life basically he plays baseball and
he trains for baseball he doesn't want
to be dealing with elements Blue Jays of
course they have a dome retractable Dome
it reminded shohi a lot of the saporo
Dome where he played with the fighters
in Japan that made a lot of sense he
went and actually saw that training
facility and was blown away by it they
just spent a hundred million bucks on a
training facility in Florida so he
likeed that uh and he's always hit well
there in Roger Center so they were a
legit option but here's the thing Dan
the Dodgers have not played a
meaningless game in the last 11 years in
the postseason literally every year he
goes to Toronto it's been the postseason
five times out of the last 11 it's not
bad but it's not the Dodgers and they
don't have a very good farm system he
could be walking into another Angel
situation with the JS so it was never
going to be the the Giants doesn't want
to play in that ballpark it's not a
great place to hit you have weather to
deal with there same thing with Seattle
I know it's retractable roof but who
knows how good they're going to be
besides they weren't even in it they
didn't have the money to do it ruled out
the Yankees Red Sox Mets right right
away The Big Spenders and that's pretty
much it Dodgers and Jays and I think
since he was in high school when the
Dodgers thought they had him signed this
was inevitable how he got there was a
shock but as far as the money at how
does it get to 700 100 like where were
the Blue Jays in this did they know what
each other's offers
were you don't really know what the
particulars are the offers but you know
the ballpark where it's going I mean we
thought going in it was going to be
number between five and six right and
these things generally tend to get
higher and it reminds me when Alex
Rodriguez signed with the Rangers way
back when he wanted money that was
beyond Kevin Garnett at the time the
highest paid athlete I didn't realize
that Messi had a contract out there at
674 so it's no surprise it gets a little
bit above that uh but obviously in
realterm value it's about 46 a year
which is just slightly above Max sherzer
Money Max sherzer 39y old pitcher nice
pitcher but he's not a two-way player
his primed like Otani so you knew what
it would take to to get Otani but he was
the one Otani was the one who presented
both to Toronto and to the Dodgers a ton
of this money is going to be deferred
because I don't want a hamstring team
that was his idea that was going to
apply to any team that signed him
talking to Tom verduchi MLB Network Fox
sports analyst and contributor to Sports
Illustrated were the Angels ever in
this not really I mean they were because
they were the incumbent team but I I
just think they knew where the number
was going and the fact that he hasn't
played a playoff game or come within 10
games to the playoffs of the Angels uh
they just couldn't match going in what
we knew the Dodgers could put on the
table in terms of competitiveness so no
I I don't think they were ever an option
I know people talked about the Braves
and they talked about the angels the
Cubs damn those teams were never really
options you make phone calls because
it's showy Otani he's once in a lifetime
if not more player so you make calls you
see where it's going but actual suitors
two that's
it and we talked about this before the
trade deadline what do you do if you're
the Angels well they decided they were
going to bring in you know players they
were going for it they were going to try
to make the postseason I wonder if they
had made the postseason would that have
changed anything in this situation with
Otani
it would have helped I'm not sure it
would have changed it um but it would
have helped I'm not sure if the Angels
were ever going to go to this kind of
number I mean they've gone over the
luxury tax threshold the first threshold
once and that was essentially a clerical
error they went over by like 75 cents so
no I I I think the run that he had there
was was unbelievable I mean that they
packed the place and I I get what Arty
Marina was doing I thought he did the
right thing by keeping Otani I mean he's
it's like owning the Mona George
Steinberger used to say that about the
Yankees there's only one Otani you have
them there and the people got to see him
for six years that that's pretty cool
but I I think Dan what people really
have to look at here is there's no
hidden agendas we have become so cynical
right that this is a case where showy
Otani and the Dodgers told me this when
they sat down with him they were blown
away by how refreshing he was like he
seems even younger than he is I always
tell people the Golden Age of baseball
is when you were 10 years old so it's
always moving but when you were 10 is
when you fell in love with the game you
looked at the game with Wonder In Your
Eyes First Time eyes Otani has never
lost that he still looks at the game
like he's 10 years old he loves the game
of baseball and I think it's a mark of
humility here and listen don't get me
wrong he's making 50 million off the
field next year Dam we don't have to
hold a ton for him right he has
endorsements more than anybody else in
the game so he's got that nice back stop
but don't try to read too much into this
we're so used to players going in there
and asking for the mood I want luxury
suits I want private planes back and
forth to home he's doing the complete
opposite and saying I'm going to defer
all this money later on so we have a
competitive team take that for what it's
worth because Show's not that
complicated of a guy what you see is
what you get baseball gonna try to close
this
loophole uh no because I think they
realize this is a unicorn player with a
unicorn cont contract this this does not
apply to anybody else I don't see
anybody else saying take 97% of my money
and defer it 10 years down the road
without interest I mean this is
completely legal if you will it's in the
collective bargaining agreement there's
nothing against it the Players
Association has no problem with this you
just won't find players who are going to
do this so it's not really a loophole
it's not like the Dodger to trying to
pull an end around here it is what it is
it's an incredible humble gesture by
this guy that you know we're always
amazed at watching him on the field and
think about this Dan his value at 700
million comes from being a two-way
player and that's about it I mean you
mentioned the story I wrote about him
very little that we really actually know
about shohi right you don't hear him
talk that much he's certainly not in
your face he's not about branding or
personality it's really about his
playing ability to me I find that
refreshing that his value is because
he's an incredible two-way player and
not about selling himself what's the
downside for the
rers boy I'm not sure what the down the
downside I guess is there might be if
he's going to pitch in 2025 he doesn't
get back to that same level of being an
ace which is possible I mean this is two
Tommy John surgeries in a short window
um in the second one your odds are
coming back are not nearly as as high as
they are the first time around but you
know what they've already talked about
if he can't come back and Pitch at a
high level or if at all you probably can
play The Outfield he's going to be able
to throw I think the question is pen he
actually got there and dominate on the
mount I wouldn't rule it out with this
guy but that's the only risk that you're
paying Otani to be a great two-way
player and maybe that pitching component
is not going to be the same from 2025 on
and I wonder what this does Tom down the
road 1015 years uh of players who now
look at this because your best player in
high school probably was a pitcher and a
shortstop and can you get a team that's
willing to allow you to do this does
does Otani open the door for this
possibility I I think you're right Dan
that it does open the door I don't see
anybody coming through it in other words
if you have a really spectacular two-way
player you bring him into your system
and you don't try to specialize right
away and you play it out as long as you
can I just don't think that there's
going to be another player who can do it
at this level and the only way you do it
is if you can max out and be a lead at
both because otherwise compromise you
become say average pitcher and average
hitter so I don't see another player
doing this in our lifetimes at this
level he's Tom verducci you can check
out his story on sh Otani joining the
Dodgers on si.com also MLB Network's new
Prime n countdown series continues
tonight with third baseman and short
Stomps uh thank you Tom great stuff we
appreciate your time as always always a
pleasure Dad thank you Tom verduchi all
right we'll take a break we'll get to
phone calls last call for phone calls
what we learn what's in store tomorrow
right after this